This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When you crank the gear of a music box, you can make the tune go as fast or as slowly as you want, as you spin the little handle around and around and around. The music is read from the series of little bumps like Braille, producer Avery Trollfum. These little bumps stick up and they hit a series of times which create a song. It's a form of storage. This is DAG Spicer, Senior Curator at the Computer History Museum. The music box is storing that program, which is the music. You think of that as software, even though you might not think of it as that, that's really what it is.
这里是“百分之九十九隐形”。我是罗曼·马斯。当你转动八音盒的齿轮时，随着你一圈又一圈地转动小把手，你可以让曲调变得和你想的一样快或一样慢。音乐是通过一系列像盲文一样的小凸起读取的，制作人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。这些小凸起向上突起，并撞击一系列时间点从而创造出一首歌曲。这是一种存储形式。这是戴格·斯派塞，计算机历史博物馆的高级策展人。八音盒正在存储那个程序，也就是音乐。你认为那是软件，尽管你可能不认为它是那样的，但那确实就是它的本来面目。
It's software. In this method of data storage, a series of bumps or series of holes, was also used in player pianos. It's also the mechanism behind computer punch cards. Go ask your grandpa about those. Throughout most of the 20th century, punch cards were the dominant form of data processing, input and output form. Paper punch card technology, the precursor to electronic computing, was the
它是软件。在这种数据存储方法中，一系列凸起或一系列孔洞，也被用于自动钢琴中。这也是计算机打孔卡背后的机制。去向你爷爷打听一下那些东西吧。在整个20世纪的大部分时间里，打孔卡是数据处理、输入和输出的主要形式。纸质打孔卡技术，作为电子计算的先驱，是
way that data was stored and tabulated for decades back when computers would take up a whole room. This technology of bumps and holes is also why you're wearing what you're wearing. Right, well, one of the things you may not know is that an early automated weaving machine actually has a role to play in the history of computing. When he says a weaving machine, DAG is talking about a loom. A loom is gigantic. Well, there are lots of different kinds of looms in different sizes, but yes, European industrial looms in the 1700s were really big.
几十年来存储和列表化数据的方式，当时计算机还要占满整整一个房间。这种凸起和孔洞的技术也是你穿着身上这身衣服的原因。对吧，嗯，你可能不知道的一件事是，早期的一台自动织布机实际上在计算的历史中扮演着一定的角色。当他说织布机时，戴格指的是一台织机。织机是巨大的。嗯，有许多不同种类和不同大小的织机，但确实，18世纪的欧洲工业织机真的很大。
About 30 feet high in some cases, and maybe 30 feet long, and it's an enormous, enormous piece of equipment. The design in a fabric is determined by how many threads the weaver goes over or under, which ones come to the top, and which ones are submerged in the weave. These patterns were so complicated and intricate, industrial weavers needed to hire little delicate fingers to pull the threads and keep track of them.
在某些情况下大约30英尺高，也许30英尺长，这是一个庞大无比的设备。织物中的设计取决于织工将线压在下面还是挑在上面，哪些线浮在表面，哪些线沉入织法之中。这些图案是如此复杂和繁复，以至于工业织工需要雇佣娇小灵巧的手指来拉动这些线并跟踪它们。
And so in the 17th century, this was a job for the drawboy, an actual boy. So your drawboy would go and say, well, we need to have the white showing through here. So I pull this one, this one needs to go all the way through, but this one needs to be skipped and on and on. So he's pulling these threads. This is Chris Garcia, also a curator at the Computer History Museum.
因此在17世纪，这是抽线童工的工作，一个真正的男孩。所以你的抽线童工会走过去说，好吧，我们需要在这里露出白色。所以我拉这一根，这一根需要一直穿过去，但这一根需要被跳过，诸如此类。所以他在拉这些线。这是克里斯·加西亚，同样是计算机历史博物馆的策展人。
It must have been murder on fingers. Well, there were tools created to help the drawboys, like forks and levers and harnesses. It wasn't all done with bare hands. But it was a lot of work to do. You could imagine if you have a significantly large item, you might have 200 threads that have to be pulled. At the beginning of the 18th century, clothes imported from China became all the rage in France, and a fashion developed for beautiful, tiny, ornate weavings.
这对手指来说一定是个折磨。嗯，当时人们创造了一些工具来帮助抽线童工，比如叉子、杠杆和背带。并不是完全用双手完成的。但这确实是大量的工作。你可以想象，如果你有一个相当大的物品，你可能需要拉动200根线。在18世纪初，从中国进口的服装在法国风靡一时，并且流行起了制作美丽、细小、华丽织物的时尚。
Making clothes that are a little bit finer, a little bit more interesting to look at, you can use a Jekarred Loom to create patterns, sophisticated patterns in that clothing. The Jekarred Loom was a device innovated by Joseph Marie Jekarred in 1804. This is an add-on. And you could attach it to the power loom. So it's like adding cruise control to your car or something.
制作稍微精细一点、看起来稍微更有趣一点的服装，你可以使用提花织机来创造图案，也就是服装中的复杂图案。提花织机是约瑟夫·玛丽·提花于1804年发明的一台设备。这是一个附加装置。你可以把它连接到动力织机上。所以这就像给你的汽车加装巡航定速或者类似的东西。
It's like an added feature so that the work product of the clothes you can produce are even more elaborate. Each new fabric design was encoded in thick cardboard cards. Each hole, a position of the hole, represents a hook on the loom. A hole in the card told the loom, yes, lift this thread. So whether the hook is raised or lowered,
这就像一个附加功能，这样你生产的服装成品会更加精致。每一种新的面料设计都被编码在厚厚的心形硬纸板卡片中。每一个孔，孔的位置，代表织机上的一个钩子。卡片上的一个孔告诉织机，是的，提起这根线。所以钩子是升起还是降下，
depends on whether there's a hole or not a hole in the jack hard control cards. Which were tied together into a loop and fed automatically into the loom. And one card represented just one pass of thread. So there would be lots of cards sewed together. And the loop of cards went around and around and around to create a repeating pattern, just like the music encoded in the music box. This didn't mean the machine was weaving the cloth automatically. It still required a master weaver and a pattern designer and a punch card maker, but it
取决于提花控制卡上是否有孔。这些卡片被串成一个环，并自动送入织机。一张卡片只代表一根线的一次穿梭。所以会有很多卡片缝合在一起。这一环卡片一圈又一圈地转动，以创造一个重复的图案，就像编码在八音盒里的音乐一样。这并不意味着机器在自动织布。它仍然需要一个主织工、一个图案设计师和一个打孔卡制作员，但它
did mean the drawboys were out of a job. Once you have a jacquard mechanism, you don't need the drawboy. Half of your workforce can be eliminated. For manufacturers who wanted to make the most beautiful, the most intricate patterns, what was increasingly more important than labor was intellectual property, the designs. In jacquard's time, people stole these control cards because they represented patterns. If they were popular, it could be very lucrative to keep making.
确实意味着抽线童工失业了。一旦你有了提花机构，你就不需要抽线童工了。你的一半劳动力可以被省去。对于想要制作最美丽、最复杂图案的制造商来说，比劳动力更重要的是知识产权，也就是设计。在提花的时代，人们会偷这些控制卡，因为它们代表了图案。如果它们很受欢迎，继续生产将会非常 lucratice（利润丰厚）。
How fashion goes in styles and everybody comes out with the same stuff every year. They're all copying each other almost, right? The same trends. I like to think of this as the first instance of software piracy that people are stealing these jacquard loom cards. And the jacquard loom cards would lead to the development of an entire new industry that would change the world.
时尚潮流是如何运作的，每个人每年都会推出相同的东西？他们几乎都在互相抄袭，对吧？同样的趋势。我认为这是软件盗版的第一例，人们在偷这些提花织机卡片。而提花织机卡片将引领一个全新行业的诞生，从而改变世界。
In 1890, a German-American inventor named Herman Hollerith devised a solution to the United States census bureau's problem of counting all the new immigrants to the country and citizens. Tabulating the census used to take about 10 years. So that means by the time the census was finished, it was already time to start taking the next one. Holworth came up with a system where if each individual's information was punched on cards, it could be processed more quickly. Herman Holworth specifically quoted the jacquard loon as his influence. His influence for coming up with computer
1890年，一位名叫赫尔曼·霍勒斯的德裔美国发明家设计了一个解决方案，来解决美国人口普查局统计该国所有新移民和公民的问题。统计人口普查过去大约需要10年时间。这意味着当人口普查完成时，已经该开始进行下一次普查了。霍勒斯想出了一个系统，如果将每个人的信息打在卡片上，就可以更快地处理。赫尔曼·霍勒斯明确提到提花织机是他的灵感来源。他构思计算机
punch cards. Once you have patterns of holes in a card, it's now machine readable and that's how the census was done in three years instead of ten. The 1890 census was a huge advance in the history of computing. Now just to wrap up the story, Hollerith's punch card patents were actually the foundation for a small company you may have heard of called International Business Machines, or IBM, which in some ways owes its existence to the loom and to that rising demand for beautiful ornate patterns.
打孔卡的灵感来源。一旦你在卡片上有规律地打孔，它现在就是机器可读的了，这就是为什么人口普查在三年而不是十年内完成了。1890年的人口普查是计算机历史上的一个巨大进步。现在，为了总结这个故事，霍勒斯的打孔卡专利实际上是一家你可能听说过的小公司的基础，这家公司叫国际商业机器公司，简称IBM，它在某些方面将其存在归功于织机和对美丽华丽图案日益增长的需求。
And because of fashion. Because of fashion. Fashion is just another word for the constant inevitable shifts in popular taste. Garments, just like buildings and cars and movies, can't help but reflect the circumstances of our moment in history. That's what fashion is. Another way of telling time.
并且因为时尚。因为时尚。时尚只是大众审美品味不断且不可避免的变化的另一个代名词。服装，就像建筑、汽车和电影一样，情不自禁地反映了我们历史时刻的环境。这就是时尚。另一种讲述时间流逝的方式。
Back and forth and back and forth. Around and around and around. The loom inspired us to the computer, the computer changed the way we buy, order and think about clothes, clothing and culture impact each other. And we need to dedicate some serious time to talking about what we wear. So that's what we're going to do. For the past eight years, we've asked you to start noticing elements in architecture and design because architecture is the art we live in, the medium in which we move, influencing us in the thousand invisible ways. For the next three weeks, we're going to ask you to do the same with another universal art that we all live in. Clothing. It's our first spinoff show hosted by Avery called Articles of Interest.
来来回回，来来回回。转呀转呀转。织机启发我们发明了计算机，计算机改变了我们购买、订购和思考衣服的方式，服装和文化相互影响。我们需要投入一些严肃的时间来谈论我们穿什么。所以这就是我们要做的。在过去的八年里，我们一直要求你们开始注意建筑和设计中的元素，因为建筑是我们生活的艺术，是我们活动的媒介，它以一千种隐形的方式影响着我们。在接下来的三周里，我们将要求你们对我们生活的另一个普遍艺术——服装，做同样的事情。这是我们的第一个衍生节目，由艾弗里主持，名为“兴趣文章”。
And it will be right here twice a week for the next three weeks in your 99 P.I. feed. We'll have the first episode after this break about what happened to working children like those drawboys and how their clothing changed. So what are you wearing right now? Oh jeez, okay. So what I'm wearing now, this is a black shirt from like American Apparel, and it's like a f***ing Godfabric.
它将在接下来的三周内，每周两次出现在你的99 P.I.订阅源中。休息过后，我们将播出第一集，内容关于那些像抽线童工这样的童工后来怎么样了，以及他们的服装是如何改变的。那么你现在穿的是什么？哦天哪，好吧。那我现在穿的这个，这是一件来自American Apparel的黑色衬衫，它就像是一块该死的上帝面料。
I can't explain it. My friend and colleague Joe Rosenberg is a really good dresser. He just has this rich understanding of textiles and cuts, and you can just tell in all these subtle ways. Below that is a seven-for-all-man kind jeans. They make pretty good kid-sized jeans, which is what I wear. Joe shops in kid sizes. I'm four-foot-eight.
我无法解释。我的朋友兼同事乔·罗森伯格是个很会穿衣服的人。他对纺织品和剪裁有着丰富的理解，你可以从所有这些微妙的方式中看出来。下面是一条七人组（Seven For All Mankind）的牛仔裤。他们制作相当不错的儿童尺码牛仔裤，这也是我穿的。乔在儿童尺码区买衣服。我身高四英尺八英寸。
I guess you could say I'm a little person in so far as I am literally little. But I don't think of myself in that way. I'm just the size of a 10-year-old. Joe doesn't have the typical dimensions of someone with dwarfism. So it's called, and I'm going to botch the pronunciation. It's called Spondalo, a pithythial dysplasia. It's a mutation that I developed as an embryo. To demonstrate how rare it is, like, I mean, my entire life I've only had one occasion
我想你可以说我是一个小矮人，因为我字面意义上就是个小个子。但我不这么认为。我只是一个10岁孩子的身材。乔并不具备侏儒症患者的典型体型。所以它被称为——我要把发音弄砸了。它被称为脊椎骨骺发育不良。这是我在胚胎时期发育的一种突变。为了证明它有多罕见，我的整个人生中我只有一次机会
to meet someone who was my height and was short in the way I was short. It was in a partying college, senior year of college, I still remember it. And we talked about, we talked about clothes. Articles of interest. A show about what we wear. And so maybe the ideas about clothes. You can attach ideas about clothes. An idea of home to a piece of cloth. These are desolars.
遇到一个和我一样身高，并且以我这种方式矮的人。那是在大学的一个派对上，大四的时候，我仍然记得。我们谈论了，我们谈论了衣服。兴趣文章。一个关于我们穿什么的节目。所以也许关于衣服的想法。你可以把关于衣服的想法联系起来。把家的概念联系到一块布料上。这些是……
Or mage, eo, oka, aime, oka, aime. Any fork and wear clothes. But if you haven't got the attitude and style to carry it off, man, you're just the clothes balls. Clothes are records of the bodies we've lived in. Think of an old sweater you used to have that's just not your style anymore, or jeans that just aren't your size anymore. We are like snakes who shed our skins and grow new ones as we age. And it all starts in the kids department. It's all gonna get.
或者……任何人都可以穿衣服。但如果你没有驾驭它的态度和风格，老兄，你只是个衣架子。衣服是我们生活过的身体的记录。想想你曾经有过的旧毛衣，它已经不再符合你的风格了，或者不再适合你尺寸的牛仔裤。随着年龄的增长，我们就像蜕皮的蛇一样，脱去旧皮，长出新皮。这一切都始于童装部。这一切都将……
Oh wow. Joe and I went to J Crew together. He was pretty much ready to give up as soon as we walked in. We haven't even dove in yet. I know we haven't. The kid section was one row. And everything in it was very loud. Ooh.
哦哇。我和乔一起去了J Crew。我们刚一进去，他就差不多准备放弃了。我们甚至还没开始深入了解呢。我知道我们还没。童装区只有一排。里面的一切都非常喧闹。噢。
This shirt glows in the dark. This shirt glows in the dark. This shirt has many tie-. This shirt goes in the dark. This shirt has many tie-dye bicycles on it. This shirt has so many stripes that maybe it almost works. The color palette of the children's department tends to be really bright and way over-decorated as Joe and I debriefed in his car.
这件衬衫在黑暗中会发光。这件衬衫在黑暗中会发光。这件衬衫有许多领带……这件衬衫在黑暗中发光。这件衬衫上面有许多扎染的自行车。这件衬衫有太多的条纹，以至于它几乎快要起作用了。童装部的调色板往往非常明亮，而且过度装饰，正如我和乔在车里进行复盘时所讨论的那样。
The fundamental thing about shopping as a very short person having to shop for kids clothes is that your life is just this hellscape of like ripped jeans and deliberate patches and fun slogans and crazy zippers and bold colors and prints and the idea that you're gonna find just like slim jeans in a subtle hue. Dark wash. You know, like, no. It just doesn't happen.
作为一个极矮的人，不得不买童装的购物的核心问题是，你的生活简直就是破洞牛仔裤、故意打上的补丁、有趣的标语、疯狂的拉链、大胆的颜色和印花的炼狱，而那种你能找到色调微妙的修身牛仔裤的想法。深色水洗。你知道的，根本没有。根本不会发生这种情况。
It almost makes no sense. You'd think that we would all start as young blank canvases, dressed in shades of white and gray, slowly acquiring more and more colors, more graphics, more signifiers of who we are as we age and solidify into ourselves. Until we finally retire in genes that we've ripped into stress and patched ourselves, paired with graphic t-shirts that list all the bands we've heard and TV shows we've watched
这几乎毫无意义。你会以为我们所有人开始时都是年轻的空白画布，穿着白色和灰色的色调，随着年龄的增长和自我的巩固，慢慢获得越来越多的颜色、更多的图形、更多关于我们是谁的标志。直到我们最终退休时，穿着我们自己撕裂、做旧并打上补丁的牛仔裤，搭配印花T恤，上面列出了我们听过的所有乐队、看过的电视节目
and cities we've visited throughout our lives. But no, all that decoration and phony self-expression is put in a blender with birthday cake and sequins and then put in a hanger on a rack. That's the kid's section. It's bad. It's really bad. And actually, even if I'm just alone, I'm like slightly embarrassed for myself. So how did we get here? Where did this style we call children's clothes come from? Children's clothes haven't always been a thing. And historically, especially in the United States,
以及我们在生活中访问过的所有城市。但事实并非如此，所有的装饰和虚假的自我表达都被放进搅拌机里，与生日蛋糕和亮片混合在一起，然后挂在货架上的衣架上。这就是童装区。它很糟糕。真的很糟糕。事实上，即使我独自一人，我也觉得有点为自己感到尴尬。那么我们是怎么走到这一步的？我们称之为童装的这种风格是从哪里来的？童装并不一直都存在。从历史上看，尤其是在美国，
childhood itself was a luxury. Because you have working children, children of parents who are not slaves, that have to work and the children who are slaves and have to work. And maybe don't have a childhood much really at all. This is Erin Algeo. She's the curator at the Lissice Museum of lace and textiles in Berkeley. Some children are always clean and some children are always precious and some are not. That's class, that's whether someone is slave or free.
童年本身就是一种奢侈。因为你有做工的儿童，不是奴隶的父母的儿童，他们必须工作，还有作为奴隶必须工作的儿童。也许根本没有什么真正的童年。这是艾琳·阿尔吉奥。她是伯克利利西斯蕾丝与纺织品博物馆的策展人。有些孩子总是干净的，有些孩子总是珍贵的，而有些则不是。这就是阶级，这就是某人是奴隶还是自由人。
The children who were not considered clean or precious didn't get children's clothes. I'm sure you've seen pictures of children that are working, and they do book my little adults as they're standing in the cotton mill or boys that go down and work in the mines. Basically, poorer children were given what was around, while upper-class children had the privilege of being deliberately dressed. And although fancy children were also sometimes dressed like little adults, underneath their clothes, a lot of them were wearing corsets.
那些被认为不干净或不珍贵的儿童没有童年服装。我确信你见过童工的照片，他们在棉纺厂里看起来确实像我的小大人，或者去矿井里工作的男孩。基本上，较穷的孩子穿的是身边有什么就穿什么，而上流社会的儿童则有特权被刻意打扮。尽管浮夸的儿童有时也被打扮成小大人，但在他们的衣服里面，他们很多人都穿着紧身胸衣。
If your parents wanted to raise you correctly, they would put you boys and girls in corsets. There's this whole idea that children had to be cultivated, like a dog and a harness or a flower on a trellis. Now the corsets were not as intense as older women wore, but yes, boys and girls were it was considered preposterous and so forth that you would be in a corset. And although it happened slowly, the demise of the child corset is thanks to philosophers like Jean-Jacques Rousseau. Our concept of childhood that we have now was really formed in the 18th century. In 1762, Rousseau wrote, in the 18th century. In 1762, Russo wrote,
如果你的父母想正确地抚养你，他们会让你——男孩和女孩——穿上紧身胸衣。这里有一种普遍的观点，即儿童必须像栓着背带的狗或架子上的花一样被精心栽培。现在，紧身胸衣不像年长女性穿的那么极端，但是是的，男孩和女孩——人们认为不穿紧身胸衣是荒谬的等等。尽管发生得很慢，但儿童紧身胸衣的消亡要归功于让-雅克·卢梭等哲学家。我们现在所拥有的童年概念确实是在18世纪形成的。1762年，卢梭写道，在18世纪。1762年，卢梭写道，
hold childhood in reverence, and do not be in any hurry to judge it for good or for ill. Give nature time to work before you take over her business, lest you interfere with her dealings. It made the concept that those little bodies needed to be free, free and unfettered. Side note, Russo himself was a terrible dad. He dropped his children off at an orphanage and abandoned them.
对童年保持敬畏，不要急于对它的好坏做出判断。给大自然时间去发挥作用，然后再接管她的业务，以免你干涉她的事务。它创造了这样一个概念，即那些小小的身体需要自由，自由且不受束缚。顺便说一句，卢梭本人是个糟糕的父亲。他把自己的孩子送到孤儿院并抛弃了他们。
But philosophies like his, paired with eventual child labor laws and regulations, really helped shape our idea of what a precious, valuable time childhood is. In the 18th century, clothes just for children come in and they look different than adult clothes. In these clothes, children are dressed up for the occasion of their youth. This amazing time free from cares, separate from the rest of their lives. They were designed for ease of movement. When we look at them today, we can't believe anyone could move in them. They may have been easier to move in than a corset, but these clothes were still really formal,
但像他这样的哲学，再加上最终的童工法律和法规，确实帮助塑造了我们对童年是多么珍贵、宝贵时间的看法。在18世纪，专门为儿童设计的衣服出现了，它们看起来与成人服装不同。在这些衣服中，孩子们是为了他们青春的节日而盛装打扮。这段摆脱了忧虑、与其余生活分开的美妙时光。它们是为了便于活动而设计的。今天当我们看着它们时，我们简直不敢相信任何人能在里面活动。它们可能比紧身胸衣更容易活动，但这些衣服仍然非常正式，
like embroidered dresses for girls and boxy little suits for boys. But it just looks like a little suit, I guess. Dorable. Yeah, no, it is adorable, actually. So children are wearing these adorable mini-me get-ups. It's almost like a parody of adulthood. Stuff meant to look like adult clothes that adults would never actually wear,
比如女孩的刺绣连衣裙和男孩的方正小西装。但它看起来就像一套小西装，我猜。太可爱了。是的，不，其实真的很可爱。所以孩子们穿着这些可爱的迷你版成人套装。这几乎就像是对成人的嘲讽。那些旨在看起来像成人服装、但成年人实际上永远不会穿的东西，
which is what we see now in the kids department. And it has everything to do with our evolving concepts of childhood and how much freedom and protection we think children ought to have. Because although their corsets are long gone, children are still bound by legal requirements. What is this thing you gave me? This is from the NRA.
这正是我们现在在童装部看到的。这与我们不断演变的童年概念以及我们认为儿童应该拥有多少自由和保护息息相关。因为尽管他们的紧身胸衣早已不复存在，但儿童仍然受到法律要求的束缚。你给我的这是什么东西？这是来自NRA的。
No, not that NRA. The National Retail Association of Australia. My friend Morgan is not Australian. She is a technical designer for a big children's clothing company. She'd rather not say which one. One of the major children's clothing retailers in the United States. Her company has many, many, many rules about what can and cannot be in children's clothes, but those rules are top secret.
不，不是那个NRA。澳大利亚国家零售协会。我的朋友摩根不是澳大利亚人。她是一家大型童装公司的技术设计师。她宁愿不说哪家。美国主要的童装零售商之一。她的公司有很多很多关于童装中可以做什么和不能做什么的规则，但这些规则是最高机密。
So Morgan brought me that Australian Safety Guide because it's kind of similar and it gives you a rough idea. This is 76 pages long and thorough and it gives you a rough idea. It's a 76 pages long and thorough, and it goes through at the beginning the way you assess risk, which is high to low based on if a kid could die from it. You don't want choking hazards, no sharp edges, and no draw strings.
所以摩根把那个澳大利亚安全指南带给我，因为它有点类似，并且能给你一个大致的概念。这有76页长，非常详尽，它能给你一个大致的概念。它是76页长且详尽的，开头部分讲述了你如何评估风险，根据孩子是否会因此死亡，风险分为高到低。你不想看到窒息危险、没有锋利的边缘，也没有拉绳。
Globally, there are reports of various serious injuries and deaths occurring when knots toggles or cord ends become snagged or caught into moving parts or closing doors. In order to address that, you can't have a cord that's longer than three inches, and that goes all the way up to 12 years in the United States. Sometimes in the kid's section, you can see drawstrings on hoodies or sweatpants, but those don't actually function. They're just decorative. They can't actually cinch the body, you can only cinch in between these two inches.
在全球范围内，有报道称，当结、扣子或绳端被勾住或卡在运动部件或关着的门里时，会发生各种严重的伤害和死亡。为了解决这个问题，你不能有一根长于三英寸的绳子，在美国，这一规定一直适用于12岁的儿童。有时在童装部，你可以看到连帽衫或运动裤上有抽绳，但那些实际上并不起作用。它们只是装饰性的。它们实际上不能收紧身体，你只能在这两英寸之间收紧。
It's basically so that kids can look like little adults without running the risks of adult dressing. So the clothing companies don't get in trouble. I mean, you can get sued for sure if you could kill kids, you know. They're not doing it just for a sense of morality. These guidelines are the cobbled together aftermath of a series of disasters. It's just like lawsuit after lawsuit. Every time an item is recalled or clothing company gets sued for endangering a child, the guidelines get revised or tightened.
这基本上是为了让孩子们看起来像小大人，而没有成年人着装的风险。这样服装公司就不会陷入麻烦。我的意思是，如果你能杀死孩子，你肯定会被起诉的，你知道的。他们这样做不仅仅是为了道德感。这些指南是一系列灾难拼凑出来的后果。这就像是一场接一场的诉讼。每当有商品被召回或服装公司因危及儿童而被起诉时，指南就会被修改或收紧。
And one of the biggest legal differences between children and adult clothes is flammability. Flammer chart is a huge one. Everything has to be flammure charted, if they're sleeping. If a child is going to sleep in it, the fabric has to be flammure charted, and the garment has to fit tight. They are concerned about candles, nightlights,
儿童服装与成人服装最大的法律区别之一是易燃性。阻燃图表是一个大问题。如果它们是用来睡觉的，每件东西都必须经过阻燃图表测试。如果孩子要穿着它睡觉，面料必须通过阻燃图表测试，并且服装必须紧身。他们担心蜡烛、小夜灯、
fires in house, whatever could happen. If their kid is wearing loose fitting clothing and it's hanging loose from you, it's just gonna to like have a lot of oxygen to give you a bunch of their degree burns. Anything that could potentially be sleep wear has to be in your skin tight and has to be flame resistant so that doesn't happen to kids. And this starts to get at our question about why kids clothes look the way they do, because note how Morgan said anything
屋里的火灾，无论可能发生什么。如果他们的孩子穿着宽松的衣服，而且宽松地挂在你身上，它就会有很多氧气，从而给你带来大量二度烧伤。任何可能成为睡衣的东西都必须紧贴皮肤并且必须防火，这样就不会对孩子发生这种情况。这就引出了我们关于为什么童装看起来像现在这样的问题，因为注意摩根是怎么说的
that could potentially be sleepwear. Flemability rules don't just apply to clothes labeled as pajamas. They could apply to any garment a parent puts their kids to sleep in. Or that a kid decides that they want to sleep in it. So anything that is comfortable or soft, which means that kids clothing, if it's not sleep wear,
任何可能成为睡衣的东西。阻燃规则不仅适用于贴有睡衣标签的衣服。它们可以适用于父母让孩子睡觉时穿的任何服装。或者孩子决定他们想穿着睡觉的任何衣服。所以任何舒适或柔软的东西，这意味着童装，如果它不是睡衣，
has to go through great pains to prove that it's not sleep wear, so that they don't have to meet all those flammability and size requirements. So let's say you're trying to design kids clothes that are not for sleeping. They can't have pictures of anything that could be interpreted as sleepy.
就必须费尽周折证明它不是睡衣，这样它们就不必满足所有这些易燃性和尺寸要求。所以假设你正在尝试设计不是用于睡觉的童装。它们不能有任何可以被解释为睡眠有关的东西的图片。
Like what is pictured on it? Is it sleeping animals? Is it a sleepy scene? Does that make you feel sleepy? If it makes you feel sleepy, it's sleep-ware. So no images of the moon, no images of stars, and no clouds. You know, like a cloud thing would probably wouldn't work. You're a legal department at your company.
比如上面画的是什么？是睡觉的动物吗？是一个沉睡的场景吗？这会让你觉得困吗？如果它让你觉得困，它就是睡衣。所以没有月亮的图像，没有星星的图像，也没有云。你知道的，像云朵一样的东西可能行不通。你是你公司的法律部门。
You're like, you can't do that because that makes me feel like sleep. And then certain animals, like owls. Same with other nocturnal creatures, like bats. Unless you're designing a Halloween line, and you really, really, really want to have a shirt with a bat on it. But I don't know if it was on Halloween and it had enough like sequins on it
你会觉得，你不能那样做，因为那让我想起睡觉。然后某些动物，比如猫头鹰。夜行动物也是如此，比如蝙蝠。除非你正在设计一个万圣节系列，并且你真的、真的、真的很想有一件印有蝙蝠的衬衫。但我不知道如果它是在万圣节穿的，并且上面有足够多的亮片
or something, maybe you could get away with it. Sequins are a good way to show a garment is not for sleeping. Same with glitter and action graphics and bright colors and ornamental pockets. You could bring it enough out of sleepwear that a kid would never want to sleep on it, so make it uncomfortable or make it a jacket or something like that. It's decoration as a form of protection, defending kids from fire and also protecting the companies from liability. Sometimes behind the glitter and garishness is a legal subtext. Sometimes, not all the time.
或者类似的东西，也许你能蒙混过关。亮片是表明一件衣服不是用来睡觉的好方法。闪粉、动作图案、鲜艳的颜色和装饰性口袋也是如此。你可以把它带离睡衣的范畴，让小孩子永远不想穿着它睡觉，所以让它穿起来不舒服，或者把它做成夹克或类似的东西。这是作为保护形式的装饰，保护儿童免受火灾，同时也保护公司免受责任。有时亮片和花哨的背后有着法律的潜台词。有时，不是一直如此。
No, I would say that they believe that they're giving you something more special, something more marketable by putting chachkis on the garment. This is Lana Hogue, an industry expert who's been working in garment development and production for over 30 years. And the sequence are usually to appeal to the child. Do they do a lot of test groups and focus groups of little kids? You know, I think they should more.
不，我会说他们相信，通过在服装上添加小物件，他们是在给你更特别、更有市场价值的东西。这是拉娜·霍格，一位在服装开发和生产领域工作了30多年的行业专家。亮片通常是为了吸引孩子。他们对小孩子做过很多测试小组和焦点小组吗？你知道，我认为他们应该做更多。
I have not seen that anywhere. Really? I worked. Manufacturers will ask parents what they're looking for in terms of styles, but not the kids themselves. They don't have any money. Probably the closest they've come to focus groups and test groups were the photo shoots. Well, in fit sessions, we want to see how something fits, but if they're kind of, oh, it's
我在任何地方都没看到过。真的吗？我工作过。制造商会询问父母他们在风格方面的需求，但不会直接问孩子。他们没有任何钱。可能最接近焦点小组和测试小组的就是照片拍摄了。嗯，在合身试穿环节中，我们想看看衣服穿起来是否合身，但如果他们有点，哦，这很
itchy and they want out of it, then you know that that's probably just a special occasion dress. It's not going to be their favorite item. But it's not like you'd cancel a garment because a kid didn't like it. No, unfortunately they don't still. So the loudness of the kids department has to do with safety rules, but not entirely. So it's not because of flammability. It's because of what kids want, but we don't ask kids what they want. It's what we think kids want.
扎人并且他们想脱下来，那么你就知道那可能只是一件特殊场合的礼服。它不会是他们最喜欢的单品。但这并不意味着你会因为孩子不喜欢而取消一件衣服。不，不幸的是他们仍然不会。所以童装部的喧闹与安全规则有关，但并不完全是。所以这不是因为易燃性。这是因为孩子想要什么，但我们不问孩子想要什么。这是我们认为孩子想要什么。
Exactly. No, I think you're right. But if you took a child into the store and you're walking around, a lot of them are drawn to the silly things hanging off a garment, but only up into a certain age. And I think that kids go through a really awkward period where they're trying to figure out what's cool again, because they don't trust their their previous taste. Although this is true for anyone at any age. We move out of one face and into the next. Unless you are trapped in the children's section and
完全正确。不，我想你是对的。但如果你带一个孩子进商店并四处走走，他们中的许多人会被挂在衣服上的傻气的东西所吸引，但这只限于一定的年龄。我认为孩子们会经历一个非常尴尬的时期，他们试图弄清楚什么是酷的，因为他们不相信他们之前的品味。尽管这对于任何年龄的任何人来说都是真实的。我们从一个阶段进入下一个阶段。除非你被困在童装区
forever relegated to this bright, loud, strange way of dressing. The pocket, strange way of dressing. There's a portrait painted on the things we love. Articles of Interest was made by myself, Avery Truffleman, edited by Joe Rosenberg, music by Ray Royal, intro and outro themes by Sassami Ashworth, fact check by Graham Haysha, mixed by Kelly Coin, and Roman Mars is the adult supervision of this whole series. A very special thanks to Cassia St. Clair, Susie Fur, Juliet Heinle, N'Rue Solomon, and the smitten, mitten audio collective in Detroit, as well as Katie Mingle, Emmett Fitzgerald,
永远被流放到这种明亮、喧闹、奇怪的着装方式中。口袋，奇怪的着装方式。我们热爱的事物上画着一幅肖像。由我本人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，乔·罗森伯格剪辑，雷·罗伊尔配乐，萨萨米·阿什沃思制作片头和片尾曲，格雷厄姆·海沙核实事实，凯利·科恩混音，罗曼·马斯是整个系列的成年人监督员。特别感谢卡西亚·圣克莱尔、苏茜·弗尔、朱丽叶·海因尔、恩鲁·所罗门以及底特律的“手套”音频集体，还有凯蒂·明格、埃姆特·菲茨杰拉德、
Sharif Yusef, Vivian Lee, Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstead, the whole 99PI team. When you think of old-timey little kids, one of the main costumes that come to mind is the sailor suit, like Donald Duck wore. A little naval costume for the cute little future man. You're being part of the establishment aren't you literally by putting your kids into kind of something they might one day grow up and become. It's rather perverse but there we are. This is Professor Jonathan Ferris and he says that in the United Kingdom, the equivalent of the sailor suit was a little plaid kilt with a suit jacket over it.
谢里夫·优素福、薇薇安·李、德兰妮·霍尔、库尔特·科尔斯特德以及整个99PI团队。当你想到老式的小孩子时，浮现在脑海的主要服装之一就是水手服，就像唐老鸭穿的那样。为可爱的小未来男子准备的小海军服装。你是在成为体制的一部分，对吧，字面意思就是把你的孩子打扮成他们有一天可能会长大并变成的样子。这相当变态，但事实就是如此。这是乔纳森·费里斯教授，他说在英国，水手服的等价物是苏格兰格子呢短裙，外面套一件西装外套。
Because this was once the uniform of the Catholic soldiers in Scotland. It was a very popular choice if you were a wealthy family to dress your kids in. To be like little soldiers? Yeah, little soldiers, tough boys and girls. The little plaid guilt was common for upper-class boys. And then, this uniform spread to girls
因为这曾是苏格兰天主教士兵的制服。如果你是一个富裕的家庭，把你的孩子打扮成这样是一个非常受欢迎的选择。就像小士兵一样？是的，小士兵，坚强的男孩和女孩。苏格兰格子呢短裙是上流社会男孩的常见打扮。然后，这种制服普及到了女孩身上
when they were also able to attend school. Your next article of interest is plaid. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当她们也能够上学时。你的下一个兴趣文章是苏格兰格子呢。来自PRX的Radio Tapio。这个集数还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子来留下评论。